the era of the gas guzzler is nearly
over this is such an interesting time to
be in this industry where it kind of
feels like the
more strong carriages
roughly 30 new electric vehicles are
coming out in the next year some being
introduced to the public at the Chicago
Auto Show the largest in the U.S it's
the year that we're going to start
seeing some electric vehicles being sold
in segments that Americans in particular
want to buy things like inexpensive
crossovers things like pickup trucks and
we're going to see some inexpensive
electric vehicles as well later on this
year but really start bringing that
electric vehicle to the masses there are
plug-in trucks like the 2023 Ford
Maverick priced for a broad Market at
just over twenty thousand dollars
Hyundai is expanding its offerings of
electric SUVs and sedans like the new
2024 ioniq 6 that can recharge nearly as
fast as gasoline models take to fill
we're trying to make the experience of
charging and maybe like pumping gas in
terms of the time stamp that that takes
in your life so those Ultra fast
Chargers are coming online more and more
throughout the United States joining
classic EVS such as the Chevy Volt are
high-end sports cars it's like the 2024
Corvette e-ray hybrid there are also the
concept cars previews of cars not yet on
the road like the Ram 1500 Revolution
battery electric truck
when it comes to plug-in cars the U.S
lags other countries about five percent
of new car sales compared to 80 in
Norway but with government incentives
that is changing California aims to ban
sales of new carbon-based cars and light
trucks by 2035. electric vehicles are
becoming more and more mainstream and
manufacturers say in the coming years
there will be a wider variety of styles
and prices
as the new models roll out the old ones
are getting phased out Dodge is offering
its last call on seven models including
its petrol-powered Challenger and
Charger muscle cars to be replaced by
Electric versions one more sign that the
future is electric John hendron Al
Jazeera Chicago